Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today, Ruffians, for our 73rd episode!
73rd!
I don't know, I feel like...
We're getting to the serious numbers, huh?
Right!
Serious!
A human year is 73, you're like, retired.
And we've had FUWAMOCO Morning for every year, huh?
Right.
But FUWAMOCO Morning is not retired any time soon.
No.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning program held every Friday.
Friday!
Wednesday!
Monday!
A.K.A FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Even the Ruffians know this!
Don't know this, Ruffians!
Is it a program?
If you're 73, you might refer to it as a program.
If you're not, it's a show.
I'm putting the 73 into the episode today, okay, Ruffians?
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Moco-chan's desperate, please tweet them!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
Nothing is different!
No!
BAU BAU!
Well, oikaisen!
Nothing is different.
And yet again!
It looks like some Ruffians have spotted Pero.
Nothing's different.
Well, where was Pero spotted then?
Uh...
De-den!
Is Pero going for a swim?
Maybe he's just taking it easy and relaxing in the water, you know?
Maybe trying to get away from all the busyness in the world?
Or did he drown?
He can swim.
What do you think it is, Ruffians?
I've never seen Pero swim before.
Why would he swim?
He's just calm, he's hanging out, huh?
Well, it seems like the Ruffians are a bit unsure.
But, I don't know, I was thinking, you know, it seems like maybe he was planning to do some serious swimming with that swim cap on.
Right!
But maybe, you know, the calmness of the water kinda got to him and made him change his plans.
But I feel like if he wants to just float then, he should probably get out of there, right?
That area is reserved for the people that are zooming back and forth, right?
Doing all the swimming.
Yeah... It's pretty nasty to be there, huh?
He's in the way, yeah... Yeah, I do think it's probably for the best you know, that you decided to do your swim far away from him, okay?
Yeah, you know... Yeah, he's taking up the lane, huh?
He's nasty.
You don't know what he could do.
Swim far away, okay?
Swim away.
BAU BAU!
Avoid.
Aquatic Predator Pero!
I don't know.
He's polluting the water.
Yeah, he's nasty, so... Avoid.
Pollution Pero.
BAU BAU!
Well, well, well!
There's been some big news!
Nanashi Ume-senpai from hololive Promise has hit 1 million subscribers on YouTube!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
You know, we were stuck in Power World.
It's too bad!
You know, but!
But!
Let's all say a big, big congratulations to Mumei-senpai, okay?
This is absolutely huge.
It's huge!
Huge!
Congratulations!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU!
And we'll work hard to get them too one day.
One day!
BAU BAU!
Such happy news, right?
Right!
Congratulations, congratulations, alright!
BAU BAU!
Well, also very happy news!
Well, on Wednesday, FUWAMOCO made an appearance on the official hololive English channel and together with Ino-senpai!
Senpai!
Ino-senbei!
Paco-senbei!
Tako-senbei!
Makes sense.
Are you just thinking about food right now?
Hungry straight from the morning, we have to have breakfast.
I don't know, I guess you know the way you make tako-senbei is you have to put the tako through the machine that makes it fly.
I think Ina-senpai would probably go through it pretty easily, right?
FUWAMOCO and Ina-senpai.
Not Ina-senpai, Ina-senpai.
We're together as Ina-senpai and Bey-senpai.
We revealed the key visuals for this year's big hololive expo and fanfest!
BAU BAU!
Did you think of the Ruffians?
Cute!
This year's outfits are super cute aloha-style polo shirts with high-waisted shorts.
And of course, you know, Moco-chan and I are matching and we're ready to make a diary of all our memories.
But more surprisingly, Pero is there with us in all of Advent for the photo too!
Surprising, huh, Ruffians?
Yeah, you know, and I know a lot of Ruffians pointed it out, but it kind of looks like we're being pretty nice to Pero there too, huh?
Well, you know,
That was just for the photo, you know.
We can't be mean in a photo.
And he's holding the balloon string for a reason, Fuwako.
But I guess we're glad that he was included.
You know, he probably doesn't even realize how lucky he is.
You know, the nasty guy.
But we really can't wait until X was here and then we can make a lot of memories together!
And also, there was the expo visual, but there was also the stunning 3 key visuals for Pithfest as well!
What did you think, Ruffians?!
You didn't take your breath away!
I sure did for eyes.
Yeah, eyes senpai look angelic and bright.
Right!
And there's three of them, so if you haven't seen them, go check them out!
Okay?
It's just one.
Yeah, you know, each visual for each stage is so exciting and just... You can't help but imagine what's gonna happen, so... You really won't want to miss a single one for sure.
Okay?
Ruffians.
Will you be going to see Fashion Person at FUWAMOCO Party?
Or are you gonna be enjoying it from your home?
Hey!
Maybe even having a watch party together with other Ruffians!
Oh!
Even better!
You'll be there!
Embracing from home!
Going to fest!
Oh!
But you can have a watch party with all your friends too!
Oh, you have a venue ticket?
Cool!
Yes!
Don't forget your ticket.
Okay, bye!
You have no friends!
Are you kidding?
You have other Ruffians!
Yeah!
The Ruffians are your friends, okay?
Okay, I'm going!
BAU BAU!
Okay, got it.
Ruffians are your friends.
I decided that.
Yes, really.
Yes.
Okay.
But we really can't wait until Expo visits us.
Yeah, we really hope that.
You know, you're looking forward to it just as much as we are because, oh my goodness, March is gonna be fun.
BAU BAU!
It's gonna be crazy!
You have friends now, you do!
You do!
Okay.
I told you, you do.
Yeah.
And that's- I'm always right.
That's the decision.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, we also saw this the other day on Twitter and we just couldn't stop thinking about it!
I couldn't.
Have you seen this?
Ruffians!
Well, it's FUWAMOCO 64!
And 64 kills!
Right!
It's perfect!
This is exactly what...
And you know right now, it's just a video, so it's not an actual game.
Giving gifts like this is absolutely amazing!
I know.
We'd love to see something come together in an actual game one day!
Maybe!
Yeah.
I wonder though, what kind of enemies would there be or NPCs to interact with?
What kind of quests would there be?
Right!
Do you think the other Advent members, do you think they'd be NPCs to talk to us, or... How about the boys?
BAU BAU!
There's so much life stuff, right?
The ideas are limitless.
Thank you so much!
Can you play as Fuwawa too?
Yeah, I think you should.
You know what type of player?
You can tag team and switch out.
High five, switch out!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
So amazing, creative, thank you!
Let's take a look at it!
Wow, Ruffians!
Marine Senchou Senpai, you know how she just recently reached 3 million subscribers, right?
Crazy.
That's amazing!
Right!
3 million... Well, you know, she promised that if she reaches 3 million, then she'd share something deeply embarrassing from her past.
A game that she made while she was still a middle schooler.
Yeah, that's...
That's the thing.
It's pretty embarrassing, I guess.
In theory, yeah.
Did you hear, Ruffians?
Yes, she got famous!
Yeah!
Yeah, well the game is titled Second World.
And apparently it's something that she worked on here and there in the past, you know, maybe.
First as a manga, and then started making a RPG maker, but then she didn't get, I guess, further in it until she was once in hololive.
Yeah, I don't know sharing something like this from
It sounds a bit rough, but it's definitely something you need to check out too, okay?
Marine Senchou Senpai also did a stream recently where she shared it, but you can also download it and check it out yourself, okay?
It's rather text-heavy though, so it might be hard if you aren't very confident in your Japanese.
Right, really impressive.
Dude, the FUWAMOCO has something...
This is crazy.
This is amazing, okay?
We don't need to talk about FUWAMOCO.
This is amazing!
You know it.
Not those kind of things.
But, you know, Ruffians!
Let's all congratulate Marine-senpai for sharing something so embarrassing and personal.
Yeah!
You know, that's amazing.
We should say a big thank you too, so... BAU BAU!
What did you do, Fuwamo?
We didn't do anything, you know.
I wish I did something as amazing as that.
It's pretty amazing!
I know.
Well, Ruffians!
We also have a bit of a confession maybe that we should make.
Well, it doesn't have to do with any of the things that we made in the past, you know.
But, well, recently, you know, we've been kind of trying to figure out what we should watch while we quickly eat our meals.
Because, you know, it's kind of nice to check up on what new anime there is, but...
But sometimes it's hard to watch an episode of anime, you know?
You have to start, stop, start, stop, you know?
Doesn't really work.
Yeah.
So, recently, we started watching episodes of GameCenter CX again!
Have you heard?
Have you heard of it, Ruffians?
It's a show where a comedian, Arino, from the duo Yoiko, he plays retro games, he tries to beat them up, showing just what makes them so special.
It's really funny and interesting. We've been able to learn a lot too.
Yeah, you love it?
Yeah!
It's so fun!
You haven't watched it, huh?
You haven't?
It's fun, though!
But, Ruffians.
A confession.
Yeah, you know... FUWAMOCO is like shouting at the TV a little, but... Of course in the most politest way possible, right?
Yeah!
Yeah.
Can you believe that?
Right?
Yeah, you know, uh... I don't know, FUWAMOCO, somehow we kinda... We kinda maybe... Think we have the authority to boss them around.
Do we?
I think it just happens, huh?
You know he's Mocoto, right?
And you know, especially when you just saw that in the Just Have Fun category of gamers.
Right.
Yep, we saw.
You think we have the authority?
Really?
Did you see the Mario Kart?
My god that jump!
Jump!
What are you doing?
BAU BAU!
My Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Spike!
He's tiny!
The puppy of puppies!
Spike, you know, he's just a little fluffy.
BAU!
So cute!
He's only just two months old and he really likes to eat and sleep and play.
He's two months old!
He's just like you!
You're two months old!
Is this our youngest Doggie of the Day?
I think so!
I think so, right, Ruffians?
You're gonna steal him!
Oh no, watch out!
He smells so sweet!
I bet he does too.
Very cute!
How does Mike BAU BAU?
Not see you, Space Cowboy!
What?
That's not how he BAU BAUs.
That's not what he does!
BAU and see a space cowboy BAU BAU.
That's not what he says, okay?
He's two months old.
Yeah.
He probably... BAU BAU BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
But he's a bit unsure.
He's just learning how to use the barker still.
The barker, yeah.
Maybe sometimes I bark.
BAU.
How big is he now?
I think he's gonna be a big puppy one day.
I think the Ruffians want updates, huh?
Well, you know, you say that his favorite things are sleeping and eating and playing, but you missed actually, you missed one important one.
Do you know what it is?
You!
Yeah, it's you!
Spike loves you!
BAU BAU!
Biting things?
I guess that one too.
I guess.
That goes in the playing category, no?
Does it?
I think so.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's check what Ruffians are doing on walks.
Well, today's... Today's the day I lay out on a walk is...
De-den!
It's so pretty!
A beautiful day!
The water bank is flowing over!
That must have been a lot of rain.
It looks so nice.
You wouldn't think it has rained recently, huh?
We hope you had an amazing walk and that your shoes didn't get soggy or anything.
BAU BAU!
Kinda scary, you have to be careful.
No soggy.
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day, we have De-den!
Hello!
It's always nice to see how you two get along, and how warm you are to each other.
Of course!
Was there ever a time when you didn't get along, or have you always been friends?
A time when we didn't get along... What do you think, Ruffians?
Huh?
Well, you know... Don't worry about it, that's one thing.
What?
Married from birth?
But you know, you see siblings, they do grow through phases, I think.
But we've always been close, you know?
Never like a... Kind of one way or the other.
You know, I think we've just been very, very thankful to have a good friend and a wonderful sister by our side for a long time, right?
Always.
Right, Moco-chan?
Over 2,000 years!
Huh?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah, of course.
You didn't answer me so I was worried a bit.
I forgot.
I wasn't listening.
BAU BAU!
Maybe that's the key to a good friendship.
Don't listen all the time.
Baby.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
For our next stream coming up, we have... De-den!
Our collab!
Our weekly collab together with Advent.
This time we're not playing anything happy like Tall World.
We're heading into the back rooms.
We're playing inside the back rooms.
Yeah.
Ruffians, we're really hoping that we don't find anything too scary and that we can find, I guess, the exit pretty fast.
Go inside the bathrooms, go outside the bathrooms, that kind of thing.
Oh yeah.
I hope there's no one lurking in the darkness who would like to be the sixth member of Advent, huh?
I definitely don't see anybody there in the thumbnail, I thought right.
Yeah.
It's a room, but it's in the back.
That makes sense.
It's the back room.
BAU BAU!
Not the bathroom.
Not the bathroom!
The back room.
No!
I'm not going inside the bathroom.
Would you rather go to the back room?
Moco-chan, you could ask me, would I rather go inside the bathroom?
I'm not gonna ask.
I don't know which one's spookier.
BAU BAU!
This weekend we're playing Metal Gear Solid 2!
We're playing it from the very beginning on our PS2 because it's Metal Gear Solid 2.
I'm really excited!
We can't wait to see what it's like now that we've upgraded from PS1 to PS2.
Right!
Right, you excited?
I'm excited!
And, it's not there, but I, in a while now, just under a week, there's a... Something that's not Metal Gear Solid 2, huh?
BAU BAU!
But first, Ruffians, we wanted to say thank you for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Amelie!
BAU BAU!
Comfy Kuwawa.
DM.
BAU BAU!
Gin Izuru.
Greek.
BAU BAU!
Madman.
Kikitoe.
BAU BAU!
Pandaromics.
McVery.
BAU BAU!
A Lost Someone.
Kuroneko.
BAU BAU!
Nomus 47.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!